hi i'm priyanka vergaria and this is ai
simplified where we learn to make
our data useful in this series we've
been learning about
ingesting data training models and
getting predictions
it would be handy to learn how to
automate all of these tasks by
implementing them programmatically in
this video we will learn how to do
exactly that with the vertex ai sdk
now before we dive into the sdk let's
take a quick look at the options to
interact with vertex ai
there is google cloud console it is the
ui to work with our model assets the
data sets the endpoints and the
predictions in cloud
now so far we've been using the console
in this series so you must be familiar
but if not i've included the links to
the previous episode below
now anything that you can do through the
ui you can also do programmatically
and for that we have the google cloud
vertex ai sdk
and then there are vertex ai client
libraries which help us make
calls to the vertex ci api
now the benefits of using client library
is that they are optimized for
languages that you choose to use for
example java python
or node now the question becomes when to
use the console
and when to use the sdk the ui helps us
get familiar with the features and
functions
available in vortex ai
so for that reason using the ui
is my go-to recommendations if you are
new to machine learning
and ai or just prefer to do things
visually
the sdk is best if you're looking to
programmatically
implement the steps in your ml workflow
now if you are an experienced machine
learning engineer
or data scientist then you would benefit
from the ease of automating your
workflow
if sdk isn't available in the language
of your choice
then you can use the client libraries or
the rest api
now that we know the different ways to
interact with vertex ai we need a fun
example to play with and create a model
using the sdk
i've picked out the perfect data set for
this
beans well who does not like beans
being a math nerd i found out that
pythagoras
yeah the one who came up with a squared
plus b
squared equals c squared that pythagoras
had an aversion to beans
who would have thought right okay so
here's the game plan
overall we will get the data explore it
a little bit
then create a model and deploy it to an
endpoint from which we can make
predictions and we will do
all of this using the sdk
we will need the tools to explore the
data and prototype this ml model
now for this we will use notebooks
within vertex which is the hosted
jupyter lab notebooks
they come pre-installed with your
favorite machine learning workflows such
as
tensorflow or pytorch these frameworks
are already installed and you also have
customized
hardware so you can use the cpus and the
gpus if you need it
it also integrates with git so we can
customize and initialize
a git repo within the notebook and it
also integrates with other google cloud
services
so we'll put our data into bigquery
which is google cloud
enterprise data warehouse and inside the
notebook
we will download that data from bigquery
and then put it into use to explore that
data using pandas data frame
and then the next step would be would be
to create our training job
creating the vertex ai model deploying
it and then making predictions and then
finally monitoring that job in the
console
now ready to go let's see it
now in the vertex ai console we can
create a hosted jupyter notebook
and if we click on the new instance we
see that there are different types of
notebooks that we
can choose from they come pre-installed
with our favorite machine learning
frameworks
and we can add gpus if needed and can
also install additional libraries
after the notebook is created i've
already created a notebook here
so let's get into it the first step is
to download our data
i'm using dry beans data set from uci
which i have linked below
this is a tabular data set that was
taken from images for different types of
beams and different data points were
collected on each type of beam
in manufacturing and other industries
it's common to extract
tabular metadata from images and use
that to train a model
i've already uploaded the data in
bigquery
and we can see the different data points
in the schema
the label that we are predicting is
called class
and we can run this quick query in the
data set to see
roughly what the distribution of bean
type is across our data set
so here i'm using the bigquery client
library to download that data
inside my notebook as pandas data frame
and using this pandas method we can see
a plot
of how the data is distributed by
parameters
next we use the seymour library to
create a pair plot
which can help us identify our
relationships between the features in
our data
and the label column within the class
now that we have a good idea of what our
data looks like and how it is balanced
we are ready to kick off the training
job in vertex ai
we initialize the project that we want
to use
then to train this model using automl we
first need a data set
we can pass the url to the data in
bigquery
directly to vertex ai there's no need to
manually move our data vertex will
handle that
for us now if we go in vertex ai console
into our data set we can see our created
data set here
and then we can see more details such as
the schema
and the data source in bigquery we could
kick off the training job here but
i trust that you can click a button so
let's stick to the sdk for this one
back in our notebook here is the code to
create the training job
this is a classification model where we
are classifying the beans into
seven classes so we define that and pass
all the different features that we want
to use in the training this model
you could add more options here such as
how you would want automl to optimize
the training
specifically useful for an imbalanced
data set
i'm not doing that here finally job.run
will run the training job we specify the
data set we want to use
the target column or label that we are
predicting
how long we want to run the training for
and enable early stopping so vertex ai
stops the training
if it does not see that the model can be
further improved
now you specify this which is useful to
keep the cost
low once the model has trained this
could take some time
we can see in the console that the
training job has
finished and we can see the evaluation
metrics
to see how our model actually performed
the confusion matrix
shows how good a job our model did in
distinguishing the different bean types
since this is a tabular model vertex ai
also gives us
feature importance out of the box with
auto emma
we can see the features in our data set
that signaled our model's prediction
the most here it looks like shape and
eccentricity
were the most important features now
that we have our model created
let's deploy our endpoint so we can use
it to serve predictions
you can do that right here in the ui but
let me show you how to do that in the
sdk
all you have to do to deploy the model
is
model.deploy and the type of machine
type you want to use
there are more things you can specify
here but i'm just going with the minimum
once created we can see it in the
console and test to make predictions
from our endpoint
let's head back over into our notebook
and see how to make predictions
using the api we provide a test set
then we need to create the endpoint
object
grab the resource name from the deployed
model and use it here
and then we use that to make a
prediction request to our endpoint
and there's our prediction
we just trained an automl model and made
prediction
using the sdk we could use the same data
set to train a custom model too
all using the sdk here are the code
samples that can help you do that
try it out yourself and if you need help
refer to the links below
alright so today we created a bean
classification model
using the vertex ai python sdk
give this a try yourself and let me know
how it goes in the comments below